hey this is preshtal Walker ABC is a
triangle with a right angle at B let AQ
be the angle bisector of a and let a q
have length equal to 9.
let c p be the angle bisector of C with
length equal to 8 root 2.
the question is what is the length of AC
the hypotenuse of the triangle
I think the punch and David for the
suggestion
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try when you're ready
keep watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
this is an extremely challenging problem
and I admit I wasn't able to solve it I
posted it on Twitter for help and I want
to thank everyone who replied in
particular I want to thank ryjoy and
Peter Lee who sent a trigonometric
solution which I will present in this
video
to get started let baq be equal to Theta
then since we have an angle bisector qac
is also equal to data
now in Triangle ABQ we have a b is equal
to AQ multiplied by the cosine of theta
now we know AQ is equal to nine so a b
is equal to 9 cosine Theta
now since triangle ABC is a right angle
triangle angle C and angle a add up to
90 degrees
this means C is equal to 90 degrees
minus two Theta
since we have an angle bisector each of
these angles will be half of that so
each of them will be equal to 45 degrees
minus Theta
now consider triangle bpc here we have
BC is equal to CP multiplied by the
cosine of 45 degrees minus Theta we know
the length of CP is equal to 8 root 2.
we can then use the cosine formula for
the difference of angles
we now evaluate cosine of 45 degrees is
equal to sine of 45 degrees is equal to
1 divided by root 2. we put that in and
then we distribute so we get BC is equal
to 8 cosine theta plus 8 sine Theta
now let's consider the entire triangle
ABC
BC divided by a b is equal to the
tangent of two Theta we can then use the
double angle formula to get that this is
equal the two tangent Theta divided by
one minus tangent squared theta so let's
just look at these equations
from the equations for B C and A B let's
take BC divided by a b
we can then divide through by 9 cosine
Theta so we get that BC divided by a b
is equal to 8 9 tangent theta plus eight
over nine
we now have two different equations that
are equal to BC divided by a b so we can
set them equal to each other
so we have two tangent Theta divided by
one minus tangent squared theta is equal
to eight over nine tangent theta plus
eight over nine
let U be equal the tangent of theta
so we can substitute in here we now have
one equation just in the variable U
we'll now simplify this equation
we'll multiply both sides by 1 minus U
squared then we'll multiply both sides
by nine
then we will distribute and move
everything over to one side so we have a
cubic equation 4u cubed plus four U
squared plus 5u minus 4 is equal to zero
how can we solve this cubic equation
one thing is we can look for rational
roots
by the rational root theorem we can have
the following candidates we want the
factors of the constant term so the
factors of 4 will be one two and four
and we want to divide that by the
factors of the leading term so this will
be the factors of 4 on U cubed so we
want plus or minus 1 2 and 4 divided by
one two or four
so this leads to the following
candidates we have plus or minus one
one-half one over four two and four
so we can try out these candidates and
we actually get lucky here we get that U
is equal to one over two is a solution
to the cubic equation
great so what do we do from here
so we know that U minus one over two is
a factor of the cubic equation so we can
do polynomial Division and this is equal
to a quadratic equation four U squared
plus six U plus eight we now Factor this
cubic equation one factor is U minus one
half the other factor is the quadratic
equation so from the first Factor we
have the root one over two we can use
the quadratic formula to get the roots
of the quadratic equation they end up
being complex Roots now since U is equal
to tangent Theta we want to limit this
to U equaling one-half so we'll get rid
of these extraneous roots
so we figured out that U is equal to
one-half this is equal to tangent of
theta let's now solve for cosine Theta
and sine Theta so let's set up a
triangle where Theta is here we have one
over two which is equal to the tangent
of theta this means the hypotenuse is
the square root of one squared plus two
squared which is equal to square root of
five
therefore cosine of theta is equal to
two divided by the square root of 5 and
sine of theta is equal to one divided by
the square root of 5.
we go back to our original setup and we
have equations for a b and b c but we
know what cosine Theta and sine Theta
are now so a b is equal to 9 cosine
Theta we substitute in and we get that a
b is equal to 18 divided by root 5.
we have an equation for BC in terms of
cosine Theta and sine Theta we
substitute in and simplify to get that
BC is equal to 24 divided by root 5.
we know what a b and b c are equal to so
we get that AC is equal to the square
root of the sum of the squares of a b
and BC
we substitute in we get the square root
of 18 squared divided by 5 plus 24
squared divided by 5. we do a little bit
of arithmetic and we get that AC is
equal to 6 root 5 which is approximately
equal to
13.416 and that's the answer
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on YouTube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve The World's problems one video at
a time